[Music]
you
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation we're gonna have a
vote shortly so I'm going to need lights
up in the house where we won't know who
won
next speaker you should know is on a
Wednesday May 21st at sick ball Kabir
who is the guy who started Grameen Phone
in Bangladesh which started the cell
phone revolution which is bringing about
2 billion people out of poverty these
days and his theme is that that works
for technology across-the-board
technology empowers the poorest after
that my old teacher Paul Ehrlich in June
June 27th he's taken on a new field in
his 70s which is human cultural
evolution and he'll be talking about
that I think for the first time in June
now the idea of the long now actually
its size was determined by Peter
Schwartz who's here in the middle seat
that it's ten thousand years of the past
because what's how long we've been doing
agriculture and towns and domesticating
animals and ourselves and things like
that and the next 10,000 years with the
idea that whatever the story is we're
right in the middle of it not at the end
not at the beginning the right in the
middle but one of the peculiarities is
this odd asymmetry between the last
10,000 years and the next 10,000 years
past and future are different animals
and they have different disciplinarians
who teach us about them and very few in
fact I think no futurists have actually
had historical training is that right
Peter yeah there you go and not that
many historians even want to speak about
the future that we have won tonight so
there's a philosophical epistemological
disciplinary mindset between these two
areas which is quite different and so
tonight we have leading practitioners
one of each now the way these long now
debates work we've had one so it's now a
tradition
is the audience decides who goes first
that person then comes up here and holds
forth for exactly 15 minutes and goes
and sits down and is interviewed by the
second speaker for 10 minutes just
basically drawing them out it's not a
debate point making deal it's a it's an
interview and then that person who's
doing the interview has the job of
summarizing the first speaker's argument
to that person's satisfaction and then
they reverse roles second speaker comes
up for 15 minutes gets interviewed for
10 minutes and so on all this time some
of you will be writing questions I hope
which will be forwarded up to Kevin
Kelly who will process for the best ones
and bring them up to be I'll be up here
on the stage and at that point and
throughout the questions will be keeping
questions coming up you guys are in the
thick of it as well I've been asked to
give some framing for how to vote and
one is in a story and one is a futurist
the existing entity that in a sense both
are dealing with is this recent book by
Neil Ferguson called the war of the
world it is about the 20th century in it
is a dark bleak grim book the age of
hatred is the subtitle in England not
here and Peters books tend to be things
like inevitable surprises the art of the
longview one called the long boom and
they're all future-oriented
so we're about to have a vote and you
are too you should be thinking about
what you want not join some title flow
but actually you know do your vote it'll
be a hand and if you want to say
something you can and I don't know which
one I'll go first okay who want Neil
Ferguson to go first
all right hands down how many want Peter
Schwartz to go first I make that as
slightly less do you guys agree that the
Neal is we just won the vote do you
think Neal won the room or we could do
this like the Democratic primary and
[Laughter]
Neal you're on well it's a great
pleasure to be here I'm a huge fan of
the long now we've been trying to make
this happen for some considerable time
and I can only say it's a great honor to
be on the same stage as Stuart and Peter
since time is not on my side I'm now
going to cut the flattery and get
straight to the point
there's one thing that I think Peter and
I agree on and that is that there is
ladies and gentlemen no such thing as
the future there are only future's
plural however there is only one past
I'll be at a past which can be
interpreted in multiple ways now I want
to explain to you what the past is and
then what history is the past it used to
be said is another country that's not
true it's another planet and it's a
planet inhabited by the dead and the
dead outnumber us massively according to
the population Reference Bureau from
50,000 BC when Homo sapiens first
appeared until the 1990s I haven't
updated the figures a hundred billion
human beings have been born so the
current world population is about six
percent of all the human beings who have
ever lived and the past is that other
planet where the dead majority lives
what historians do is to try to
understand that planet
what they can't do and I want to be very
clear about this they can't establish
universal laws of social or political
physics with reliable predictable pars
there are two reasons for this the first
is that there's no possibility of
repeating the experiment called history
the sample size of human history is N
equals 1 the other problem is that you
can't really have physics when the
particles have consciousness
particularly the kind of consciousness
that human beings have evolved which
interestingly enough turns out to be
especially skewed when it comes to
understanding the past our heuristic
biases are very bad when we try to
assess past events so that's what
historians can't do but ladies and
gentlemen they can do some important
things nevertheless they can do is first
they can analyze and interpret human
experience in the past at multiple
levels we can go from the micro the
individuals experience to the macro the
entire experience of humanity over short
or long time periods it's a very
flexible discipline in that sense and we
work in a certain rough-and-ready way
that's not such a bad thing we can with
a rather coarse-grained approach we can
draw analogies between different
situations in the past all between
situations in the past and situations in
the present for example we can quite
easily make comparisons between
financial crises over time they have
certain common features even although no
two can be said to be identical the same
goes for geopolitical crises and Wars
the other thing that historians can do
which is quite clever in my view there
hardly any of them do it I do it
compulsively as we can imagine or
simulate alternative pasts and I used
the term advisedly because there is only
one path
fake pasts that didn't happen but might
have and they're a terribly important
device for understanding what did happen
it was a great Lewis name you who once
said that historians could only really
be said to be doing their job well if
they had an instinctive sense of what
didn't happen part of the point of my
book the war of the world is to explore
a particularly important counterfactual
scenario needless to say we have jargon
for this procedure a what if question
what if question is what if World War
two had broken out in 1938 that's a very
core of the book I'm not giving up away
too much when I say that it would have
been a shorter war and many many fewer
people would have died but now the
critical thing to understand is how
historians do what I have just described
how do we do it
well the answer is that we commune with
the dead we do sounds quite weird when I
put it like that to be honest being
historian as a rather morbid possibly
psychotic activity I genuinely prefer
the company of the dead I spend much
more time with dead people than with
people like you and I'm sure future
psychologists will explain this in ways
that are not favorable to me however I
have a rationale for this at which I
will explain RG Collingwood who is one
of the great philosophers of history
produced by my old University Oxford
once said in his wonderful brief
autobiography and I quote historical
knowledge is the reenactment of a past
thought encapsulated in a context of
present thoughts which in contradicting
it confine it to a plane different from
theirs that's actually the single most
important sentence ever written about
historical methodology in my view we are
re-enacting past thought
and we can only do this by communing
with the dead through the records that
they have left of their past thoughts
what did it feel like to be an ethnic
German in Central and Eastern Europe
after 1918 that's one of the questions
that I try to address in the war of the
world but historians don't just do that
the other thing that we do
simultaneously in a completely different
methodological way is that we try to
infer what Karl Hempel called covering
laws about the way that that the human
past has operated from mainly
quantitative data there is a kind of
rough-and-ready covering law at the
heart of war of the world and it goes
like this if you have simultaneously
economic volatility ethnic
disintegration and empires in decline
each of these begins with the letter e
which makes it easy to remember then the
probability of a high level of organized
lethal violence is significant
probability not certainty this isn't a
law it's not a model in the way that
social scientists would tend to to think
it's just a statement of a rough
regularity take these things together
economic volatility ethnic
disintegration and empires and decline
and violence is likely to be
significantly higher than under
different circumstances
now what if futurists do if that's what
historians do in a nutshell the answer
is that they infer future scenarios on
the basis of past examples and past data
but without necessarily acknowledging
that the analogies they're drawing are
historically inspired they claim to be
concerning themselves with the future
but in reality they are as much
concerned with the past as historians
because what else do they have to go on
it's not the power of prophecy with
which Peter is endowed what he is trying
to do is infer from the past future
plausible scenarios now I don't think
that's a bad procedure and I want to
make it clear that this is not the House
of Commons and I'm not here to oppose
everything he says on the contrary we in
fact have much in common and being asked
to do this forced me to ask myself what
don't we agree about we've known one
another for at least 10 years and much
of the time we are in almost beautiful
and perfect harmony but it seems to me
there is a methodological problem that
Peter not being a historian may
underestimate about what he does and the
problem is this if you are constructing
future scenarios on the basis of past
data without adequate historical
training you are more likely to be
susceptible to the kind of heuristic
biases that I mentioned before because
scenarios are in fact as he himself
acknowledges plots for unmade movies
that is what they are and it seems to me
that they are inspired as much by his
own personal predictions as by any very
rigorous assessment of past data I won't
go through the full list of heuristic
biases of which I think he may be guilty
though it is quite tempting I wanted
because time is limited give you a tale
of five futures the two futures that are
implied in my book and which I made
explicit in an article that was
published in foreign affairs shortly
after the book was published and the
three futures envisaged in Peters book
the art of the long view my future is
very simple I make the point in the war
of the world that we can learn from the
history of the 20th century that
scientific and economic progress does
not reduce the risk of organized lethal
violence on the contrary despite the
advances that we made economically
scientifically and otherwise in the 20th
century we proved to be capable of
unprecedented levels of murderous
behavior
we should learn from this that
globalization is vulnerable may even
generate its own destruction
that there is a potential for conflict
regardless even of levels of education
and that the three things I mentioned
earlier economic volatility ethnic
disintegration and empires and decline
can still cause high levels of violence
in our time the implicit second future
is that we learn from history and make
sure or at least endeavor to make sure
that these things do not coincide again
in other words aware of the fragility of
the order we call globalization we do
our best not to have a 1914 the ass
belongs use a wonderfully stimulating
book and deserves all the praise that's
been heaped upon it and it contains
three future scenarios for the period
between 1991 when it was written and
2005 and it's fascinating to read these
now three years after 2005 the three
scenarios Peter favors three rather like
the UN with its population projections
there's they're cheerful there's a
gloomy and there was just right the
Goldilocks future the three futures have
some of you will doubtless know from
your reading the following titles new
Empires market world and change without
progress I'm not sure which movies
inspired the first two but he admits
that the third the pessimistic one was
inspired by Blade Runner it's clear that
of the three the middle Goldilocks
projection has come closest to being
right it is a kind of vision of
globalization and there's much in it
that I admire an understanding of the
way in which computer microworlds he
uses a term that hasn't really caught on
would transform the way in which the
world works there's even a 1997
financial crash full marks however
there is a missing elephant or rather
giant panda in scenario one China quote
goes its own way preoccupied with
territorial disputes with India in
scenario two China causes a financial
crisis by defaulting on its debts to
Japanese banks and scenario number three
the Bladerunner scenario China fights a
major war with India using Pakistani
weapons the only thing that I can find
to salvage this story is that China in
scenario three quote exterminated the
Tibetan independence movement well that
may turn out to be dead right but
everything else that Peter wrote about
China in his best-selling book has been
wrong and to be wrong about China is to
be wrong about the single most important
thing that has happened since 1991 that
seems to me to illustrate not that the
perils of being Peter Schwartz on the
contrary it Ellis traits the perils of
being a futurist the inherent
impossibility of making predictions
about a system as complex as the world
of human beings could not be better
illustrated than by this glaring
omission in all three of the scenarios
in the art of the longview how can we
work together it seems to me we can work
together that futurists can learn from
historians and historians from futurists
I think our best hope is to make
historical inquiry more rigorous than it
is and I want to make it clear that I
don't in fact regard my profession as
particularly impressive when it comes to
standards of scientific and scholarly
rigor historians need to know more about
chaos theory they need to know more
about complexity theory they need to
know what a power law is and they
particularly need to understand
evolutionary biology they need to learn
from the sciences much more than they do
here I think we would be in complete
agreement but I want to conclude ladies
and gentlemen by suggesting that
futurists really do
need to learn from historical method
they need to understand better that
point that Collingwood made that it's
not enough just to understand the world
as some kind of hydraulic system it's
important to get inside the heads of the
dead
and if you don't do that it seems to me
your future scenarios are likely to be
worth rather less than the paper that
they're printed on thank you very much
indeed
if I wasn't - okay well first of all
thank you both for the flattery and the
critique so I have a few questions to
see if we understand first of all what
you're saying I want to come back later
to the questions of your view of the
world and where it's headed and so on
which you touched on as well but I want
to spend a few minutes on what I think
was your most central point which is the
issue of how we think about the future
and what the nature of learning from
history is so first question you alluded
to heuristic biases and you know you
said well you could enumerate them and
be fairly explicit about them please
well where to begin one of the the
greatest problems that we have when
we're thinking about the future is that
we're attracted to certain scenarios
more than to others we have a certain
confirmation bias illustrate this point
with another part of your book you were
strongly attracted to the importance of
the teenager right and the global
teenager is a key player in your book I
think that's the classic product of a
strong prior that you instinctively felt
this was important because you were once
a teenager when teenagers mattered it
would be typically a baby boomer who
thought that teenagers would continue to
matter they don't matter they become
less and less important with every
passing year the demographics not only
of the United States but of China itself
make teenagers increasingly unimportant
as a group but because you had a strong
prior in favour of thinking they
mattered you wrote a whole chapter about
the global teenager and I I strongly I
strongly feel that the global teenager
is a minor player compared with the
global oldie
and I would certainly you know say that
having addressed the major benefactors
of the Hoover institutions who are the
global holdings that's a good example
okay
another point you made which i think is
is actually quite profound
and worth exploring for a moment I think
because you you you know I think time
was running down and you touched on it
without exploring it further and that is
what the sources of learning in a sense
for the historical community in terms of
being able to look at novelty and new
things like the frontiers of science and
so on and you touched on a few of those
biology complexity and so on expand a
bit more how you would see those kinds
of ideas coming to play in the world of
history because I think it is a
challenge you know bringing these worlds
together
well it's it's most easy to do if you're
like me concerned with economic and
financial history Peter because that
there's no question that when it comes
to trying to understand financial crises
there are all kinds of benefits to
understanding complexity that that's to
say that in many ways financial systems
do behave a lot like complex systems in
the natural world that the regularity of
financial crises does not follow the the
bell curve normal distribution there are
very fat tails in the history of finance
and this is a recurrent feature that
takes you all the way from the South Sea
Bubble of 1720 to the present and so
simply understanding a little bit about
distributions of extreme events
understanding a little bit about how
systems can become critical seems to me
absolutely essential if you want to if
you want to understand how financial
crises occur that's actually more
helpful than understanding the theory of
modern finance as exemplified that by
the black Scholes formula because
actually the theories of option pricing
is based on a completely false notion
about the distribution of financial
outcomes to the effect that it does
follow the bell curve so that's one
that's one example chaos theory was
something that inspired me when I was
writing a book called virtual history
because I was acutely aware of the
sensitivity of political and social
systems to initial conditions and the
proverbial butterfly flapping its wings
can cause the the hurricane at the other
end of the earth it's important that
historians understand this because
historians have their own heuristic
biases
please make let me make that clear one
of our heuristic biases is we really do
want great events to have great causes
we hate the idea that a war as big as
the first world war could have origins
that date back no further than July or
June of 1914 we want big origins for big
Wars we want the origins to be in at
least the 1890s maybe even the 1870s and
I've read books that date the origins of
the first world war back to 1815 which
is a hundred years before it broke it
broke out now that seems to me to be
based on a fundamental misunderstanding
of the historical process that a small
Mis judgment and I think there was a
small miss judgment on the part of
political actors in European capitals in
1914 sufficed to cause four and a
quarter years of carnage one last
thought which is particularly important
to me at the moment is understanding
evolutionary biology if you are writing
as I am at the moment a history of
world finance or rather a financial
history of the world I think that's a
better way to put you can plug the name
of the books okay which is going to be
entitled the ascent of money
if you're old enough you'll remember
burn off skis a scent of man it's an
ironic pun on that 4,000 years of
financial history strongly resemble the
history of evolution in the natural
world it's almost all there there are
their great dying's there was speciation
there was natural selection and one
could think therefore of the story of
financial history as a very compressed
evolutionary story there are differences
some of the mutation is conscious it's
Lamarckian not Darwinian but it's
nevertheless it seems to me a very
helpful way of thinking about it
profoundly important historical process
I hardly need to say how important it is
this year I might say Stuart are big
fans of a book called why big fierce
animals are rare which is all about in
fact precisely that kind of evolutionary
thrust right
ok pushing on I you moving now across in
some sense the boundary between
methodology and substance you said
something I think very important but it
was in the context of alluding to
methodological issues and that had to do
with the notes of the future your view
of the future was simple that Science
and Technology had not reduced the risk
of increasing violence but you also have
a clearly the example in modern history
of mutually assured destruction in which
we avoided the cataclysmic war how do
you deal with the differing effects of
Science and Technology in that arena as
well as others that may have reduced the
levels of violence from as a result of
economic progress and better healthcare
water environment all those kinds of
sources of conflict that emerge from
advances in science well are two ways of
thinking about this one is that mutually
assured destruction might easily have
led to mutually assured destruction and
it only just failed to by a hair's
breadth on at least two occasions and
one can't again allow the retrospective
fallacy to turn the Cold War into the
long piece I'm certainly old enough to
remember how very unfair to be steering
the abyss of nuclear destruction in in
the face I must say that the more one
thinks about the history of the Cold War
the more one becomes aware of
close it came to disaster particularly
in the Cuban Missile Crisis and although
the stakes weren't quite so high in 1973
the nuclear arsenals were substantially
larger so the risks were even more
terrifying so I'm not sure I buy the
idea that just because post-hoc there
was no third world war ergo Hawk
therefore it was because deterrence
worked I think we were lucky a 1914
could have happened in the early sixties
or the early seventies the other way of
looking at it is that of course there
was a third world war it was just and
this is a point I make him in the war of
the world
it was the third world's war that having
established Arsenal's that were too
powerful to use on each other the
superpowers waged a war that was just as
destructive in terms of human life as
the first world war
indirectly by proxy through a succession
of third world countries and so in a
sense the volume of violence didn't
decline in the world after the invention
of the atomic bomb it didn't decline in
a substantial way by the end of the
century that was still the potential for
genocide and it could still be carried
out with extremely primitive weapons in
countries like Cambodia or Rwanda so
that's that's the the double argument
that I would make well actually you've
in your answer you've actually answered
my last question as well because you had
alluded to the the forces of economic
volatility ethnic conflict and empires
in decline as the powerful engines of
violence and expressions of hatred etc
and the question I really had for you
was what was the difference in the first
half and second half of the 20th century
and you're basically saying if I read
you right not much yeah location
location location that was the
difference because all that happened was
that the violence which in the first
half of the century was heavily
concentrated in Central and Eastern
Europe and Manchuria Korea there are
these two great killing zones at each
end of Eurasia these zones finally
become off-limits in the early 1950s
Germany and Korea are partitioned and
it's realized that fighting over these
areas is in some ways too destructive to
to happen again but the violence is just
moved and takes place in
tomorrow in Cambodia in Angola and so on
so that's the simple answer and of
course that's why my first gloomy
scenario about the future is that this
could happen somewhere else and the
obvious place today where there is
economic volatility are plenty death
nick disintegration in full swing and an
empire in decline is of course the
middle east thank you okay well it seems
to me you're talking about two obviously
related sets of ideas and the first has
to do with how one thinks about the
future
I think the wonderfully elegant eloquent
description of the planet of the past
very hard to get to we don't know yet
how to travel there and so we can only
get there my empathy as it were and I
thought the the empathy with the dead
was a very eloquent way of putting it I
think you also clearly challenged how we
think about the future in terms of the
depth of understanding of history and
what one can draw from an extremely
complex rich record and what meaning one
draws from that and particularly I think
you know and one things that I admire
about your work is the willingness to
consider and learn from alternative
interpretations of the past different
ways of thinking about what happened and
what might have happened as you did both
in virtual history and at various points
in the war of the world I think you also
rightly draw attention to the source of
novelty they ought to inform even
historical thinking when one draws
conclusions for the future and that is
sources of new knowledge from the
sciences and so on and I think you
identified several that I find
particularly important biological
thinking and evolutionary thinking
complexity and chaos and that line of
thought I think obviously you also had a
critique I think of some of my work you
know I think and I'll come back to
particularly the issue of China and how
and why but I think it is indicative of
something which you touched on and which
I'll come back to it when I speak and
then finally I think you've also
provided a framework for thinking about
the recent history of the last century
and what it implies in particularly the
focus on these things that I think this
this was new
your book I don't think people had put
this particular story together of these
three forces of economic volatility and
its impact on societies and the social
fabric the impact of ethnic and
religious conflict and its virulence and
in depth and the inability of empires to
manage the world as it were and sustain
an order in both the decline of Britain
and the failure of the u.s. to rise to
the Imperial challenge and that that
leads one to ask serious questions about
what may happen not very far ahead
particularly looking around what we see
as events like financial crises and wars
in Iraq is that if it I'm told I'm
supposed to say you got it but as I
never say you got it under any
circumstances what I'll say is yes but
there's a couple of points that I would
like to just throw in you got is my
first one of them is actually
self-criticism I wondered if you'd spot
the flaw in my argument perhaps somebody
else has I don't think I can
convincingly show that you would have
got China any more right if you had been
a historian well I'm going to make that
argument myself rule number one I'm from
Glasgow get your retaliation in first
[Laughter]
I wouldn't make the other point you're
probably gonna make it I should leave
you one head go ahead
no no I'll leave you the other one oh
I'm always I'm always satisfied with
what Peter says that was that was a mere
quibble so what I borrow your pen Peter
I don't have one I borrowed it from
Stuart please
I said to my wife Kathleen when we came
over here I'm either brave or very
stupid to take on Neil Ferguson you have
seen why I feel really honored to be on
the same stage with Neil I truly admire
his work I've read I think everything
since the pity of war
most of us who write nonfiction wish we
could write books with such scholarship
depth originality elegance of prose
their real page page turners he always
makes me think and I highly recommend
reading the war of the world which you
can buy out there and indeed this debate
came about from a dinner that Neil and I
had about 18 months ago while I was
beginning to work on a new book and that
book was optimistically titled the case
for optimism I had just finished the war
of the world and was shattered it really
challenged my thinking as each of his
books has done forced me to reflect on
my basic assumptions about where we were
headed and what it meant and it
basically stopped my book I said all
right I have got to confront the issues
that Neil raises in his book and really
think them through in a very fundamental
way and I've spent the last 18 months
doing that so in a sense you're a part
of my thought process by having this
debate I have forced myself to reach
some conclusions about the arguments
which Neil so eloquently made in his
book and as Neil rightly puts EDA's
alternative past I do alternative
futures but here's where I want to take
a small a line of difference and that is
that you know you talked about the land
of the dead what we futurists have
imaginary friends
imaginary friends in the future as it
were and and that is that we on the one
hand really do need to do good history
and I will allow that from time to time
we fail in that but I spend most of my
time reading either history or science
the things that change the future the
frontiers of the new and you know we
have to live in science with the laws of
physics there's no real beam me up
Scotty but you know yes to the flip
phone we have what Star Trek saw then so
imagination sometimes works and Neil
unlike most historians
brings imagination to his task that's
indeed what part of the virtual history
task is and indeed in the case of China
mine was a failure of imagination not a
failure I think of history in fact we
were probably too bound by our view of
the limits of how much China could
evolve and if anything I would say many
of my historic mistakes have been not
from a failure of good historical
analysis but a failure of imagination
but I will allow both of those frankly
because I have made both classes of
mistakes so now let me turn a bit to how
we think about things differently in
particular with respect to the book and
some of the arguments which you've made
about what's shaping modern times in
history and I think if I would
characterize a very simple framework for
thinking about how I think you see it
versus how I see it and which leads to
different scenarios is I think you see
the momentum of history as on a kind of
downward slope or at best flat with the
possibility that we could get it right
and reverse direction and I on the other
hand see the moment of history basically
on an upward trajectory with the
possibility that we could get it wrong
and head down so your uncertainty is
mainly on the upside and mine is mainly
on the downside and in fact I agree with
everything in the water of the world
until we get to the epilogue which is
what deals with the last 50 years it
basically the book brilliantly covers
the run-up to World War one and all the
way through the Korean War as one in a
sense continuous context of conflict and
this and you touched on this I think in
your remarks has to do with how we view
the second half of the 20th century
versus the first half I think you see
them as mostly not very different and I
see then the second half is representing
real progress where we have meaningfully
fewer deaths for example in the first
half I think in the book your number is
160 180 million the second half is
closer to 10 to 20 what that means is
the first half of the Sun century we
killed off somewhere on the order of
five percent of humanity one in 20 in
the second half it was 1/6 of 1% now if
you were you know the mother of the
soldier who died among those or the
family or was raped in Bosnia
that matters a lot but I submit that
there's a huge difference between
killing one and 20 and 1/6 of 1% and
what part of the reason is that we made
real progress in human institutions that
constrained the violence that limited
the conflict part it was mutually
assured destruction but part it was the
rule of law that limited particularly
trans-border conflicts to very few most
were civil wars they were ethnic and
violent and particularly ugly but I
submit that nothing reached the levels
of the Holocaust in that respect in
world war two we also had much wider
prosperity with vastly more people
enjoying the benefits of progress and
much more freedom and democracy in many
places and by the way there's also more
eco friendly so you know we've seen a
lot of progress so unless we blow it we
have a chance of getting it better hmm
but I will say this I want to set the
bar even higher because something you
don't touch on your book which i think
is a now at issue for the future is
climate change and so that could be
another set of conflicts or tsa's of
conflict and if we don't deal with that
then we're leaving something very big if
China was the elephant of the last
decade climate change is the elephant of
the decades ahead so I think there are
real powerful forces for progress and if
we think about the last 30 or 40 years
we've seen enormous changes that have
surprised us the rise of the women's
movement and how its transformed the
role of women in America so today four
out of five Americans say they would
vote for Hillary Clinton without
thinking about zoom it's not a hundred
percent but it's four out of five we've
seen the population bust we've lowered
the population expectations for the
future we saw the end of the Cold War
basically Soviet Union said it not worth
fighting anymore gave up went away
without violent revolution and we've
seen the dramatic transformations in
China all of these things have left the
world in a much better place and very
hard to have anticipated I got it wrong
in China so it is this sense that we can
make very real progress so if we think
about the issue of prosperity we have a
long history of increasing prosperity
more countries are in the game first it
was the US Europe Japan now China and
India
lots of new technology that increases
productivity knowledge is spreading
around the world Wikipedia is the best
new any poverty tool we've ever seen
spreading access to knowledge everywhere
and essentially no cost we see the
difference in places like Singapore
versus Nigeria where knowledge drives
growth and resources failure so many
more people have a stake today in the
system and preserving what we're doing
and indeed I would argue that even
today's financial crisis one possible
outcome is real reform again part of the
learning process of our system
I think the second big thing is that
we've learned how to contain conflict we
avoided the big nuclear war we've had
very few real trans-border conflicts
that we are have been involved in one
right now we have more means for
intervention and a great example of
getting it right is what's going on
today in Kosovo here's Kosovo declaring
independence and oh by the way the last
time that's happened there was wholesale
slaughter this time as a result of the
previous intervention we're not doing
that the Serbians aren't slaughtering
the Kosovars because they learned
something along the way they'll get hit
if they do and so in fact the system of
intervention and Prevention of conflict
is working we see it happening and I
think we'll be chastened by the Iraq war
you know we're going to find that
unilateralism doesn't work so we're
seeing improvement in the international
security systems improve governance more
and more countries are better governed
China and India today compared before
maybe even Russia new regional
governance structures EU the OAU
global level the WTO Security Council
IMF World Bank NATO and in fact one of
your articles recently which I loved and
reading Neil is a real delight regularly
it publishes a great deal you talk about
a world of powerlessness and that could
become anarchy and like the dark ages
but in fact I see and this goes back to
the notion of complexity a complex
network adaptive learning systems
bottoms up emerging system not top-down
Imperial system of many actors
governments and multinationals small
businesses NGOs supranational
institutions in a complex web of power
not an empire and then finally the
climate challenge which I put on the
table you know this is a very
issue some of you were here last year
when I debated Ralph Cabana on nuclear
power I think this is a global crisis of
great urgency and it's not hard to
imagine how it could become a source of
conflict the the history could easily be
there
imagine if the Tibetan Highlands begin
to dry up the Mekong begins to dry up
the Chinese dams begin to affect the
Vietnamese downstream and this is you
know here we have the exact ingredients
you've talked about the Vietnamese and
Chinese don't like each other very much
and you could imagine a conflict over
access to water on the other hand
climate change could be the shared
threat that really unites us that
creates a new environment for
collaboration China and India and in the
United States face the same challenge we
have huge technological resources and
capabilities I can easily imagine the
scenario that we work together rather
than work apart with rather than
conflict its collaboration and that has
happened in recent history as well so I
think many of the technology options in
a world where we both want more
electricity more cars are a plausible
scenario and particularly given the
outcome of this election all three
candidates are in favor of dealing with
climate change we could see a
fundamental change in the very near
future so I see a very different future
than I think that dark future that is
implicit in the war of the world I see a
positive second half of the 20th century
leading to a remarkable 21st century not
utopia but continued progress you know I
can see it being driven by increasing
global integration technology progress
the challenge of climate change and
sustained economic growth with some ups
and downs but doubling per capita income
by 2030
not at all implausible new technologies
like synthetic biology leading to a new
industrial revolution we had craig
Venter here last month talking about how
we were going to reinvent the industrial
society and be able to essentially make
the next several billion people rich
without destroying the world's
ecosystems using new biological
production methods in fact we're just at
a meeting the other day seeing literally
the first bacteria producing diesel fuel
bubbles of diesel coming out basically
these bacteria ship diesel and
not a distant dream but already out
there today so we could see major
development in the new infrastructure of
clean energy it's a bit like war in that
respect but a war on climate change that
Spurs growth and leads to high
employment leading to narrowing income
gaps see growth in China continue to
widen a deep and maybe even spread to
South American Africa u.s. would back
off perhaps our missile base in Europe
they're pissing off the Russians a big
thing is the question of how many of the
countries really work within the systems
of international institutions and one
could even imagine the evolution of new
security organizations that come out of
NATO including the BRICS Brazil Russia
India China maybe even a new global EPA
coming out of Asia these things could
contain and limit ethnic violence
perhaps even begin to shape new forms of
support looking toward Africa and Latin
America the brilliant new book by Paul
Collier called the bottom billion in
which he argues that we need the
equivalent of a Marshall Plan for the
poor of the world and this includes not
merely aid but also security support
because obviously what's happening in
Africa in big parts of the world are the
kind of conflict that I think you talk
about and without support security
structures it will be impossible to have
levels of development but all of that
happens best in a multilateral context
which I think can actually develop so I
think you can see how the momentum of
history I think of the last half of the
20th century perhaps may carry us
forward toward greater progress and
perhaps at mid-century we would look
back and say the world is more peaceful
prosperous equitable and sustainable and
we would thank Neil Ferguson for making
clear what the hurdles were ahead and
fortunately we would find that unlike
his pessimism we were actually up to the
challenge and a better world was the
result thank you
[Applause]
while it was a great pleasure to listen
to Peter it's my duty now to throw some
questions of you my first one is your
your faith in in technology is is of
course critical to your argument isn't
one of the difficulties that war was in
fact the great driver of technological
innovation in the mid century and it's
far from clear that technology
necessarily and always has benign
Pacific outcomes in fact technology is
strangely neutral about our future as a
species it can be as capable of
destroying us as of enriching us and
making our lives more comfortable how do
you grapple with that janus faced
character of technology in human history
well I think you're right I mean it's a
both end in fact if you look at I'm an
engineer by education not a historian
and if you look at the history of
engineering it began with fortifications
that's what the first engineers were
about building forts and then building
things to break through the forts so
that's basically what it was all about
and so it's not a surprise that the
frontiers of Technology are at the
frontiers of warfare as will and indeed
you know there's no question that the
down sides both deliberately and
potentially accidentally of technology
are obvious whether they are as we've
seen nuclear weapons or possible
biological weapons or other things we
have yet to imagine so I don't have any
doubt that the destructive potentials
both today and yet in the future of
Technology are very real that having
been said it is also the case that much
of what we say today take to be a much
better life is the result of technology
none of us would want to go to a dentist
of 1900 today you know and you don't
only needs to think about what drilling
would be like without anesthesia to
imagine just to see the smallest grain
of technological progress but I think
one of the best examples you can see is
what's happened for example at the
environment you know I think it is one
of the challenges ahead but if you look
at what's happened as a result of things
like the Clean Air Act and technology
that's come along its equivalent in the
UK and in the United States today the
air and the Bay Area is much better than
it was 30 years ago the bay is cleaner
than it was
years ago they're fishing in the Thames
which they couldn't do 15 or 20 years
ago the air in London is you know ain't
perfect but it isn't like the cold smog
of the 1950s and we've made the
automobile of today 90% cleaner than the
automobile of 25 years ago so you know I
think it's a both end I think human
progress depends upon enormous
continuing advance in technology we
can't solve solve the climate change
problem I don't think we can end poverty
without doing it and so on but we can
get it wrong the biofuels mess that's
creating some of the rice crisis that
we're having right now is a good example
of getting things wrong so technology
doesn't automatically guarantee a good
outcome what we do with it is obviously
what's critical you have to acknowledge
that much of the progress in medical
science you mentioned dentistry but but
progress in anesthesia progress in that
field was again accelerated by by
warfare actually this seems to be to be
one of the recurrent features of our
predicament that it seems to take a
massive Cataclysm to to make our
technological innovation accelerate but
there's a piece of sleight of hand that
I want to pick you up on you simplified
my argument by dividing the 20th century
into two halves a very destructive half
and a relatively less destructive half
but the book actually tries to avoid
that periodization by suggesting a
period from around 1904 to 1953 of of
Megadeth and then this lower level
conflict the third world's war in
actually less populous places the
problem is the period before it that you
don't say anything about are you ever
worried that you might be like one of
those pre-1914 intellectuals who said
war is now impossible there was Norman
Angell was a normal angel was one that
though there was a chap named Eve and
blush who argued that war had become
technologically far too destructive to
be sustainable for any length of time in
fact there were a whole group of people
who came to the conclusion the
technological progress had actually made
great power war highly unlikely and
indeed that you could see why they
thought that because from the 1870s
onwards the amount of war and
particularly the risk of great power war
seemed to be declining
something quite interesting that
financial markets were much less nervous
in the decade before 1914 than they had
been in the 1870s and 1880s so if we go
back a little bit earlier
isn't there a sort of alarmingly similar
scenario I hate to use the word scenario
a period in which a futurists a Peter
Schwartz would have said it's all gonna
be fine
technology's gonna solve our problems
we're all going to live in peace and
then 1914 comes along and the books are
all remaindered how do you address that
problem
hey the the best example we could see is
Palm Beach 2004 the kinds of events that
could deflect history and so an
unquestionably I think you're right on
this one and and I I see very much the
risk here indeed if you'd been here in
1908 you would have been enthralled by
all the new technologies the automobile
electricity radio the telephone
airplanes you know and we would have
just had Einstein published you know his
epic year and the world was about to
change globalization was very real you
know travel under the famous quarter the
you you have the quote from Keynes that
you know soon that after the man could
go anywhere in the British Empire and
you know not even need any money because
everywhere it was all good British
Sterling was available so yeah I think
the analogy is actually rather apt and
it is worrying I think it is genuinely
worrying but I think it is a matter of
choice that is I think what we saw then
and I think your book rightly argues it
was staggering misperceptions and
misjudgments on the part of political
leaders now indeed I think we've just
seen one of those catastrophes of
misjudgment and incompetence on the part
of political leadership play out in Iraq
and indeed those events are genuinely
worrying and I think you rightly pointed
to where the biggest risks in the world
live today and we have certainly
exacerbated it but it may be an
opportunity for the world and we to
learn a lesson at a fairly high price I
might add but not as catastrophic to say
Vietnam was in human death from our
point of view at least but having said
that I think the analogy ought to give
us pause because I think there is enough
merit in it and then we ought to be
thinking hard about how we not follow
that
path of kind of cascading events and
misperceptions into a war no one wanted
well I'm glad you acknowledge that part
of my objective in writing a book like
the war of the world is precisely to
make sure that I'm wrong in other words
that the objective is to force people to
think about the historical process in
such a way that they avoid war of the
world the sequel but there's a and a
part of your argument that I'm puzzled
by and that is your your optimism about
the the question of climate change when
you make the point that things have got
so much better in in England or in
California that that's because the
industrial world has been relocated to
Asia and anybody who spends any time in
East Asia will tell you that the peace
Super's of old London are nothing
compared with the kind of pollution
that's being created as a fifth of
humanity embarks on a far more rapid
industrialization than English speakers
ever a dreamt of I mean this is all
being done at a breakneck speed and it
seems to me that the the optimism that
you have that this is all going to be
resolved by I don't know microbes that
[ __ ] diesel is hard to I have to tell
you that the idea that that's going to
solve our problems is a stretch for me I
really though I'm sure craig Venter is a
very smart guy the law of unintended
consequences tells me that his diesel
shooting microbes will end up destroying
mankind taking over the world I don't
know I don't like the sign of any of
this
you know I know what HG Wells would say
about those microbes if you were here
well the the issue of China and the
environment and pollution is probably
one of the biggest challenges not only
for China but for the world and how do
we solve that cuz you didn't really say
that they don't aren't part of this
wonderful new democratic networked
system of global government yes they are
I think they are as a matter of fact and
well in fact what you know I thought
they were still ruled by a communist
bottle with a one-party state yes they
are but they're also engaged in a great
variety of efforts already dealing with
the consequences of climate change both
in collaborative efforts right here at
UC Berkeley for example in a network of
scientists and basically technical
people in a variety of different domains
trying to deal with the shared problems
that we both face but for them the
biggest issue is coal they've got to
clean up their coal they've got to find
ways to capture the carbon and sequester
it they need clean vehicles they have
exactly the same needs for technology
that we do and so my view is fairly
straightforward
there's no it ain't a done deal by any
means but very much the same technology
challenges that they face we face and
that we are likely to be working
together in one way or another or
competing you know but then driving each
other to do better in that sense to
develop the technologies of things like
clean coal and clean cars because
neither one of us will make it without
them and one already sees at least the
seeds of that in collaborative efforts
beginning what if there's another
outcome though let's build a scenario in
which something much more like the past
recurs in which rival empires fight over
increasingly scarce natural resources
and do not adopt new and more benign
technologies because it's just too damn
difficult what makes you so sure that we
won't be quarreling over coal and oil
and particularly oil and natural gas
much in the way that in previous eras
men fought wars over coal or for that
matter sugar which was a great source of
energy in there and the 17th century
well look it was access to oil the
triggered World War two you know and if
with the Japanese in particular so I
think the risks are very real though
interestingly enough I think the risks
are greater between say China and
and access to Russian natural gas for
reasons of substituting for dirty coal
cleaner natural gas and the issue of you
know who really owns Siberia may become
an issue and that one worries me as a
source of conflict well I think at this
point the time is up and that means that
I have to know it's really quite a
challenge this it's almost impossible
for anybody with jetlag to do but I've
now got to summarize Peters arguments in
such a way that he will say you got it
so my understanding is that your
argument is is as follows first that we
we both method logically are engaged in
in the same activity we use our
imaginations and we use our imaginations
to try to draw inferences from past data
the inferences I draw are about how the
dead thought and the inferences you draw
are about your imaginary friends and I
have a very good doctor that you can see
[Laughter]
so that's the first point in a sense
we're both engaged in in challenges that
require our brains computational part to
do things that no other computational
part can do and and we're not actually
ever going to be tremendously effective
in that sense that the China question is
is the interesting one you put that down
to a failure of imagination I think we
should try and talk more about that
because it seems to me to be at the very
heart of what we're discussing here and
I still don't really know if had I asked
myself that question with a somewhat
different set of historical assumptions
I would have come up with a better
answer than you so that's the first
point the second point is I'm a
pessimist and you're an optimist that's
how I interpreted much of what you said
and that you take precisely the same
data that I take from the 20th century
and come to a fundamentally Pangloss
Ian's conclusion whereas I am Cassandra
and all I can do is predict yes more
carnage I think this is a legitimate
point though it risks discrediting us
both
if we are simply writing books that
express our fundamentally different
temperaments you the cheerful West
coaster me the gloomy despondent
Calvinists scoff then there may not be
any need to read these books you just
look look at our BIOS on wiki and say
he's a pessimist he's an optimist that's
all you need to know so that that seems
to me to be a somewhat problem is
problematic proposition I hope that I
tried to transcend as best I can my my
temperamental difficulties my the
Calvinist legacy is one that it's hard
to shake off but that's I think at the
heart of the second part of your
argument so but final part of your
argument is that technology is the
driver in your approach to scenario
building you always list a bunch of
drivers they're usually about seven or
eight but but it all seems to me that
the one that you instinctively want to
put at the top and give pride of place
to is technology which I suppose is a
reflection of your your background as an
engineer and hence the notion that out
of all the troubles that we currently
face there will be technological
solutions and that with one bound or one
bacterium will be free is that a fair
summary of your arguments what do you
think unfair summary well the truth is
in substance of course it actually is
except I wouldn't say that in fact I
think it is Pangloss Ian versus a kind
of doer Scott I think it is actually the
relative weight one gives to the novel
versus the methods of history that the
forces noting methods the force of
history how much how malleable is the
human condition how much can we really
reinvent what is possible and my
impression is you would give greater
weight to the force of history and those
things that are enduring and I might
give greater weight to those things are
that are more novel and that challenge
some of those things that have persisted
for a very long time just one little
footnote to it occurs to me at one point
that you've made
recently very eloquently is that that
you may live to be a hundred and fifty
which which is an exciting thought
though I'm not sure our debate will be
that good in 50 years I can't promise to
be anything other than gaga if I'm still
around but but you know if that is
possible you might think that it would
radically change our human condition yet
the the lesson of history is that making
people live longer doesn't radically
change the human condition we actually
already have done this because life
expectancy at the beginning of the 20th
century an average male life expectancy
even and in developed or relatively
advanced European societies was still
amazingly low bar our standard late 40s
right so we got from 37 to where we are
now which in in even the more deprived
parts of Scotland is still in the upper
60s it hasn't I think radically changed
the world that we've achieved us I don't
think that we are in fact significantly
more benign I don't think our societies
are significantly improved by the fact
that people live a lot longer so this is
this seems to me to illustrate precisely
the point that you make big changes in
our technological or biological
circumstances seems to leave us
unaltered as human beings and the dark
forces within us that incline people
towards acts of violence or irrational
political decisions which are
tremendously important they don't seem
to we don't seem to be any wiser we're
definitely older but I don't think that
we're wiser I'm not sure you know you
have people now who live multi
generationally in other words there are
people today who remember the worlds of
the 50s and the 40s and even the 30s and
I think we have that process and
possibility of intergenerational
learning far more extensively and far
more deeply than we ever have before
more 90 year olds who are around
teaching their great-grandchildren
something of the world in which they
once encountered so I think that there
is an opportunity not certainly
universally taken but I do see it
happening and I see it happening
frequently of this kind of
intergenerational learning that you know
we have lots of forgetting as generation
after generation died and we have to
repeat the crises that happened again
and again and not to say that there's
universal learning but I think that
there is a kind of adaptive process that
as we live longer we
learn more and more deeply which I
sounds like an argument for the the 71
year old rather than the 46 year old in
the presidential election but Allah
leave politics out of that you guys been
characterizing each other and what
hasn't been mentioned is that Peter is
an old SDS ER and basically a liberal
cellular level I was at Columbia today
yesterday was the day and Neal for a
while there you were the darling of the
neoconservatives in this country a
comfortable company for them we can talk
about that Hoover Institution I remember
you recommending and some op-ed that
John Kerry should win because he was so
inept that he would soon be replaced by
a good Republican well actually what I
argued in the in that article was that
george w bush was so inept that we
really should replace him and not give
him a second anything yeah that was one
of the more prescient pieces i wrote in
2004 but it is there does pessimism and
conservatism blend it all does optimism
and liberalism blend it all is this it
all part of what we're talking about
besides engineers and the liberal arts
guy well I think if we are going to talk
about are as it were ideological priors
as well as our cultural background which
which historians are trained to do I
mean one tries to pick one's cards on
the table full disclosure I've done that
in all my books full disclosure my
grandfather was in the Highland
regiments in the in the trenches on the
Western Front full disclosure my family
had substantial contacts and involvement
with the history of the British Empire
full disclosure it's not a secret I was
an ardent Thatcherite
in the 1980s and have certainly been
seen as as being on the right since then
though I don't think in American terms
I'm a conservative that's all but this
is a word that means quite different
things on the two sides of the Atlantic
I'm a liberal fundamentalist I come from
the the 19th century Gladstone Ian's
tradition in British politics the 18th
century tradition of Adam Smith and the
Scottish enlightenment and I tend to
make my judgments
political parties and political leaders
on a fairly pragmatic basis are they in
favor of the free market and are they
prefer are they prepared to defend
political Liberty against regimes that
threaten it those are the two key
questions in the 1980s I think that
there's two key questions today
so I'm rather wary of being classified
as a typical pessimistic conservative
because I see myself more as a rather
old-fashioned liberal a liberal in the
in the Scottish eighteenth and
nineteenth-century sense of the word
rather than in the Barack Obama sense of
the word well you know I think you put
your finger on part of my history but
not part of what happened subsequently
indeed yes I was SDS and you know if in
the 60s you weren't you were missing the
game right and you know you were there
in your own form of your own barricades
as it were that having been said what I
happened to me was a lot of learning
along the way but not in the sense of
you know a liberal mugged by history as
it were and now conservative what I
began to learn was the nature of complex
dynamics I took my background in fluid
mechanics and tried to understand how
actually history works how the future
unfolds I spent 10 years at SR I and it
would be hard to and I can tell you it
was a remarkable moment when I was in
the board room of shell thinking back to
those moments when we were occupying
fair-weather hall at Columbia or when I
was in the executive dining room of the
CIA thinking back to those moments
because I think my thought process
evolved not so much ideologically but in
terms of methodology how I approached
the question and it was when I really
began to deal with the question of
uncertainty moving from a world that was
predictable in its fashion to a world
that was both malleable and uncertain
and indeed you know my background look I
think my friends know I was born in a
refugee camp in Germany concentration
camp survivors and slave laborers and
you have to be pretty churlish not to be
optimistic if you've climbed out of that
kind of background you know that your
parents suffered what my parents
suffered and where I began my life and
to see what I have experienced that the
world at least
forded me the possibility of which I
took but which if I said gee I'm
pessimistic based on that history I
would have to be systematically blind to
the only the possibility that I enjoy I
have to just pick you up on that very
briefly and then we'll go to some
questions from from the audience I'm
glad you mentioned your your parents
experience I must say that would make me
far more skeptical than you are of the
the benefits of of science and
technology because you have to ask
yourself which country in the world was
in the forefront of scientific and
technological advance in the 1920s and
indeed early 1930s where were the
universities most sophisticated in the
realm of the Natural Sciences between
the world wars the answer is Germany
Germany has a commanding lead when it
came to Nobel prizes in their hard
sciences it was far ahead of the United
States until refugees began to arrive
predominantly Jewish refugees from the
German universities in the American
Universities anybody who knows the
history of the mid 20th century and
particularly the extraordinary role of
Germany that most advanced of European
countries has to end up it seems to me
pessimistic certainly pessimistic about
Science and Technology now all right
here's a question from from luis rosado
what is the next China what well 20
years from now we'd be looking back on
and saying that was the elephant we
didn't even see it you've written a book
about this well what are the inevitable
surprises I mean I I basically said
climate change is the one in terms of
the one that it will be world shaping
but I think there's another one that
we're in the midst of right now that we
we can't see quite yet and you and I
were talking about this backstage if the
financial crisis that we are in
continues down the course that it may be
on toward yet a much deeper crisis then
there is the real possibility that a
long-term historical shift that was
almost inevitable with the rise of China
and India of a rebalancing of the world
financial world may take place in weeks
not decades
and that the shift of the geopolitical
and geo-economic landscape where all the
pools of capital flow and the control of
the flow of capital moves out of
democratic hands into state controlled
hands from market hands of the New York
markets the London markets into the
hands of the Chinese the cadiz the
Singaporeans the people with the great
Russians and that that could transform
the landscape of the world in a rather
fundamental way so that's one that I
think is sitting out there I think it's
a good question I think China will be
the next China that is to say that we're
getting China wrong again
the classic argument that is now
conventional wisdom was I think
originally Jim O'Neill's at Goldman it
was Jim who coined the phrase the BRICS
and it's Jim who has these wonderful
lines that you may have seen that
project
China's gross domestic product
overtaking that of the United States in
2024 on Tuesday the 15th of March at 10
past 5:00 I promise you that's not gonna
happen that is the one thing that you
can be sure not because history just is
not like that it's not linear when Japan
was converging in the United Kingdom a
process that began over a hundred years
ago it was certainly not a smooth line
although ultimately that crossover
happened I think that the trend is right
but the smoothness is wrong and I think
we're heading for a far bumpier ride in
China then the conventional wisdom
allows China is already more exposed to
the consequences of climate change
vastly more exposed than the United
States because of its very location and
topography there's a demographic
disaster unfolding as a consequence of
the one-child policy I saw some
fascinating statistics only this morning
at Hoover about the imbalances the
gender imbalances in China as a result
of sex selection the use of abortion
against female fetuses there is going to
be a huge oversupply of men and under
supply of women in many parts of China
and more seriously
there is going to be a huge imbalance
between the generations within the space
of 20 years that is going to cause
profound difficulties for China's
practically non-existent welfare state
so if I had to pick a thing that would
be an outlier at this point it would be
the China screw-up which I think is the
one thing that most people assume isn't
going to happen well you know China is
getting old before it's getting rich and
that's the wrong way to do it sure you
know the other way around is a whole lot
better none of this has ever been tried
before on their scale right so this is
this is and I should say this is where
historians may not be particularly
helpful because we are in a number of
very unchartered waters at this point
well you know you could add to that by
the way the demographics of Russia
Russia is in demographic collapse its
population is falling it's labor force
is falling fast and the only thing
covering it is $120 a barrel oiler
hmm if the price of oil Falls or they
run into hiccups in one way or another
they're Russia could really be under
enormous similar pressure that China
would be - and then what happens if
Russia or trying to go into this kind of
crisis mode what happens next well I I
think this is where the historian can be
helpful when politically fragile systems
encounter major social and economic
shocks they traditionally in the modern
period have used nationalism or some
other extreme ideology but usually
nationalism to try and really jism eyes
themselves now I don't know whether you
follow this closely I do I think the
Chinese reaction to our critique of
their policy in Tibet is quite
fascinating and startling there are some
really amazing videos that you can watch
of of a naked ly nationalist nature that
don't seem to be government generated
might seem to be or not don't seem to be
yes my strong impression is that we
underestimate the extent to which the
internet and the cell phone are allowing
not liberal progressive democratic
forces to gain ground in China but the
opposite they actually allowing a quite
old-fashioned and to our eyes almost
19th and early 20th century nationalism
to mobilize a generation in ways that
I'm not even sure the Chinese leadership
are in
so again China is the next China the
China we're gonna get is not the China
of the BRICS story it's a China with
profound social and economic problems
which it will try to address by the kind
of nationalism that we have forgotten
exists particularly we Europeans who are
kind of post nationalists in our in our
ethos our next question comes from Iran
Indyk and recently the speaker here was
nothing Tom the Black Swan okay so this
will be a Black Swan question now the
history nor futurism seems to account
for random events that dictate the
course of both the Fluke of 9/11 for
instance and can any analysis of the
past or future indicate how to basically
deal with these things that come out of
left field that are predictable only in
retrospect and they're big they change
everything well NASA team and I have
become pals lately since I reviewed the
Black Swan with tremendous enthusiasm
and he and I have this project to write
a paper which is essentially why can't
financial markets predict history and I
think one of the things that makes the
Black Swan a really good book is its
critique of the way that historians
convention they think I actually alluded
to it when I talked earlier about our
desire for enormous causes to match
enormous consequences what the Black
Swan is about is is partly the poverty
of induction as a method but mainly
actually the problem of historical
thinking in trying to explain crises so
it seems to me if you take a Talib like
view of the way that our complex modern
societies operate you're actually going
to start understanding the historical
process much better you have to get away
from smooth curves you have to get away
from the assumption that there are nice
regular cycles and historical process
this was the thing that historians spent
generations looking for and not quite
finding the Kondratiev wave all this
stuff as if history was some kind of
regular
rhythmical process but it's not it's
actually stochastic it's it's a
deterministic system but it behaves in
ways that appear random and this is not
just true financial markets is also true
say military conflicts all for that
matter revolutions so my sense is that
he's part of a very healthy tendency a
tendency whereby people who come from
very different disciplines in his case
quantitative finance inform the way that
we think about the historical process my
sense is that some of the best history
that will be written in the next
generation will be written by people
with an interdisciplinary background who
are as comfortable with that kind of
argument as they are wading through
dirty old letters left by the dead well
you rightly made the point when in your
comments about evolutionary biology as a
way of thinking about history and you
know evolutionary biology that is non
teleological so we don't have purpose
and large forces and the choices of
evolution are not planned they're the
random events that and and mutations
that come up and get tried in one way or
another and so I think the the idea of
evolutionary biology as a way of
thinking about history comes much closer
to the way in which Nasim thinks about
it than the kind of Toynbee esque kind
of neat cycles of history or Kondratiev
waves or any of those kinds of
regularities and that history is I mean
biology is much messier than say the
pendulum motion of physics that people
tried to apply as a kind of analogy to
history before I'm sure that's right you
thought we were gonna keep talking
agreed I heard this couple right I'm
sure that's right he said I love these
names Pietro OPA though this is to Neil
but it's really to both of you what do
you believe is the purpose of the
futurist do you think the futurist can
change the course of history this is a
this is reflexive 'ti as I mean we're
living history we're thinking history
the thinking of history and our features
some by professionals like Peter but
basically by all of us we're going
around with these notions
in front of us imagining that that is
the path and all the errors notions well
the great danger and this one can learn
from history is is to believe too firmly
in one of your scenarios after all it's
not as if futurists are a recent
invention it's not as if we only just
started to think of scenarios in fact
most of history is characterized by the
use of more or less crude models to
construct futures alarming Goldilocks or
exciting and it seems to me that the big
problem is that very often these futures
are so wrong that they lead to decisions
that produce even worse futures the
classic example being the one child
child policy in China the future that
the Chinese Communist Party was staring
at which was presented to them by their
demographers and and technical experts
was a Malthusian one we cannot grow
crops and rice as fast as the population
is growing we have to do something
radical we have to intervene
in the way that the planned economy is
intervened in everything else in human
reproduction and they did and this was a
very fine example of a futurist changing
the world of a planner changing policy
but the unintended consequences are I
believe going to make China much less
stable place than it would have been if
they just tried to increase agricultural
productivity and let nature take its
course in the way that it's taken its
course everywhere else at a certain
point there is a demographic transition
and people stop having really large
families they don't need to be coerced
into it so it seems to me futurists are
not new
what new I think is Peter's methodology
where you present at least three
scenarios and don't explicitly wait the
probabilities actually I hate that about
Peter scenarios I want the goddamn
probabilities please could you attach
some kind of probability to these three
scenarios and tell me which one knows
the most likely but because you weren't
seems to me your role is essentially to
present a menu to the CEOs or the
managers of sovereign wealth funds or
possibly even the rulers of Great
Eastern despotisms and say sire I have
considered I've gazed into my crystal
ball but unfortunately there are three
crystal balls and I will present you
with these three crystal balls and you
choose the one you really like to look
off and you know it's gonna be
ultimately a matter of taste which
scenario any powerful person adopts if
you don't if you don't attach the
probability so this is a new game where
you offer three that they pick one but
it could be as disastrous as the old
model where you just offer one crystal
ball hmm I think not and here I think
you got it right up until the pick one
and and that is the objective and this
is why I got into the business in the
first place I mean like a lot of people
I was fascinated by the future but
because this is in late 60s I didn't see
any futures I liked when I looked at the
ideologies of left and right and I
wanted I realized we needed better tools
for making better decisions about the
future and that's where this alternative
thinking process came from but the
important point was not to pick one
scenario but to develop essentially the
adaptive capacity on the one hand to be
able to live with multiple possibilities
to be able to influence outcomes on the
other and to be able to in a sense be
resilient against a variety of
possibilities so in its why when I sit
with CEOs or government leaders I don't
tell them what will happen I'm not
staring into that one single crystal
ball but rather my measure of success is
do they ask better questions and do they
make better decisions not did they
predict a better future I think the
Chinese had a kind of single view and
fundamentally misperceived it and it's
where governments often get it wrong is
that they have this kind of view that's
based as much on denial as anything else
so I think if one keeps the
possibilities open one is far more
likely to make much more agile choices
in the face of that uncertainty a fellow
on a question of that which is when we
start a global business network back
when scenarios were looked like they
were probably about ready to peak when
Herman Kahn started him a long time
before that and shale picked up on
did okay and then g-man grabbed and ran
with them and we figured you know usual
business fad that would be maybe five
years we were lucky we were hoping for
ten yeah we were hoping for ten one of
our scenarios was ten but that didn't
happen that became it wasn't hula hoops
it was jogging it was the thing which
just became a permanent part of the
intellectual landscape of policy of
business of government and so on are we
to conclude that the only institutions
that don't engage in Scenario planning
are financial institutions because
presumably if financial institutions had
heeded your methodology we wouldn't
currently be in the mess that we're in
because they would have had a scenario
in which a liquidity crisis came along
and a bank run caused the entire system
to Teeter on the brink of collapse no I
mean why if we've so much adopted this
methodology of the key institutions and
our economy screwed up so spectacularly
I they're just not hiring you guys
that's right but having said that that's
a new explanation for this subprime
crisis well in fact we did work with one
of the banks and they sold their sub
prime portfolio three years ago because
they did their scenarios and couldn't
see any good ones now you know who to
her but having said that look when the
self-interest is so great that the
motivation for self-deception is so
great that that's I think a big part of
what was going on here in and actually
almost always happens in financial
crisis it reaches the point where you
know you can deceive yourself well you
know I'll do one more trade it's you
know I'll have like one more shot of
heroin and then I'll stop and it's the
same way it feeds on itself and you get
runaway crises it was what has just
happened with the subprime it's happened
what happened with the derivatives
trading in 1987 it's what happened with
some of the bond and realist rate and
currency in Thailand in 1997 but now you
sound just like me you're getting a
whole series of historical examples okay
here's a a quote posed as a question
it is arrogant to be pessimistic in the
face of a 13.7 billion year trend 13.7
billion whoa really deep history right
basically since the Big Bang and things
been getting worse or getting better
that
maybe it's an entropic view in the trend
building the universe is really in
particularly great shape it's not but we
can delude ourselves that oh you're
missing biology biology is that is the
great invention of the universe in a
self-organizing way I mean you know this
but there are zero species most of them
are tiny microbes that don't [ __ ] so
much for evolution why can't you produce
diesel all by yourselves they did once
you know I mean I think the timeframe
here is crucial we haven't talked about
this but if you think about human
history you mustn't think about it as
some four thousand you know the
civilizations story of four thousand
years of continuous advance it's not
there's a hundred years of spectacular
advance and prior to that is basically
Malthus most of human history involves
people engaged in subsistence
agriculture must have organized
civilized recorded human history as
people engaged subsistence agriculture
being exploited by tiny elites it's only
with the Industrial Revolution that the
possibility exists through technologies
like through technology but my case is
made I got my butt in but but please
technology allied with major and
inexplicable gains in labor productivity
it may or may not additional copy ya
know a bit greg Clark's book of you
farewell to arms there isn't really a
very obvious explanation for why it was
that the Industrial Revolution saw
massive gains in labor productivity in a
few countries beginning with Britain you
can't actually explain it in terms
purely of technology that's one of the
things that he shows very clearly and
then from that point on there's a sort
of exponential growth which is
essentially the history of the last 150
years and that gradually improves the
loss of the average human being until
you're left with Colliers bottom billion
that's that's really the way in which we
should think about the historical
process the biggest historical question
which I don't think Greg answers is why
did heat the human condition suddenly
change when most of
history was really a rather miserable
affair well and if you look at the
numbers in terms of predicted for the US
Europe and Japan post-world War two the
rate of growth of per capita income
exploded relative to history and I would
attribute that not only the new
technology but the scale of organization
in terms of the efficiency of networks
of production and so on all of those
things experienced unbelievable progress
over the last 50 years as compared to
even the previous 50 or the hundred and
50 before that so you know we're on an
accelerating trend I'm not a
decelerating train but you assume Peter
and here is our profound difference but
that trend can be projected forward
whereas it seems to me this phenomenon
that we're describing is just an
historical anomaly and it would be
really very surprising if it were
continued in fact it's almost certainly
not sustainable over the next 150 years
so that is the big difference between us
okay so here's a history perspective
have there been past technological hurts
while Moore's law type curves that
accelerated and then broke or were they
just part of what you might call the
very long early part of this slow
astrometric now accelerating astrometric
they're saying human nutrition so for
most of human history men were and women
were malnourished you you can see that
by the size of their skeletons that
survived they really were rather short
and their lives were pretty brief they
didn't didn't take long really to be
taken out by disease if you were as
poorly fed as the average person
throughout most of recorded history and
then there was a great breakthrough
wasn't a particularly happy story I have
to tell you because the great brakes
were involved in slaving millions of
Africans and getting them to produce
sugar for the consumption of people in
Western Europe sugar is a great source
of energy if you want to understand the
Industrial Revolution part of the story
is that for the first time there are
people in the world who properly getting
the calories that they need and those
people are in Britain and at this point
you yet you start to see a shift in the
direction of proper nutrition and people
start to get better and better fed and
by the mid 20th century you
human beings getting a really good diet
but then you tip over into the obese era
because this thing can't be sustained
what happens in fact is that the habits
of the industrial era let's eat some
sugar let's have more sugar hmm that's
pretty good let's put some corn oil and
sugar and have that too
you reach a you point the reach point of
diminishing returns and you only have to
you know take a walk through I don't
know Atlanta Airport to see how
diplomatic not San Francisco progress is
not like that in the realm of human
nutrition which is the central most
important driver in many ways in the
industrial revolution story there comes
a point when you just can't actually get
any bigger as a human being you've
reached the point and Monty - Monty
Python life of Brian when you're about
to explode not life of brian meaning of
life Thank You jet lag okay here's a
specific question from waned and bork
mr. Ferguson do you feel the big nets
for both of you do you feel the big
cause and the current Middle East
conflict lay more in modern times or
more in the events of a tirado choises
histories or something else well I think
the conflicts of our time have
relatively shallow historical roots
though I wouldn't say as often people do
say that that they can all be blamed on
decisions taken between around 1917 and
1921 it's an easy argument to make that
the problems your hero Churchill didn't
get it wrong well you see it's easy to
blame British and French imperialists
for the way in which the Middle East's
landscape changed after World War one
but this is to overlook a fundamental
problem which is that the Ottoman Empire
was no it'll indeed the first modern
genocide happened before the breakup of
the Ottoman Empire in 1915 as I'm sure
everybody here knows so one can't simply
brain blame this on decisions taken when
the Ottoman Empire was broken up there
was something already badly wrong in
that region just as the process of
Jewish colonization that ultimately
produced the State of Israel predated
the first world war can be traced right
back into
19th century and I think I would look
there one has to look it seems to me to
the mid 19th century in the process that
leads up to the frost World War and then
beyond to understand the problems that
we currently face they do have to do
with that phenomenon that interests me
so much
ethnic disintegration when different
ethnic and sectarian groups become
increasingly hostile to one another to
the point of being unable to cohabit
peacefully that's a process which is is
actually it seems to me the most
interesting one to understand in modern
history
remember Samuel Huntington who predicted
in 1993 that the post Cold War era would
be about a clash of civilizations well
the history of the Middle East suggests
otherwise it suggests actually far more
complex processes particularly of
sectarian violence within so-called
civilization and that that seems to me
to be a really difficult thing to
explain why what is it that causes
Sunnis and Shias to engage in systemic
violence against one another this is a
new phenomenon in the sense that it
hasn't been seen much in in recent years
but it's an ancient phenomenon because
it can cite disputes that go back into
deep history one of the things that
makes a question like that so difficult
is that the protagonists justify their
hatred of one another in terms of the
distant past and that inclines us to
think that all of this lies I don't know
as far back as the early history of
Islam but I don't think it does I think
these are just legitimation of
relatively recent disputes between
people living cheek-by-jowl in
relatively densely populated
impoverished cities I think I would add
one thing which is alluded into in your
observation but I think there's
something in let me call it the Arab
culture North Africa Middle East that we
have seen these kinds of struggles among
families the Hashemites versus the
sounds and so on all the different sub
cultures and very much in the I think
the in the spirit of the war of the
world but that have been at each other
for quite a long time not necessarily
fighting out ancient enmities and so on
but simply family rivalries cultural
rivalries and so on for relative
dominance and post-world War
one they kind of got locked into
national boundaries eg the Saudi
peninsula and the Hashemites up towards
Jordan etc and we have transposed I
think cultural tribal familial conflict
into nationalism and that becomes
extremely difficult because it then it's
no longer quite as malleable and
amenable to the kind of compromises that
history actually allowed them to pursue
in the past the only thing I'd add to
that Peter is that before we make any
blanket our claims about the character
of Arab culture or or for that matter
Islam we should remember that although
the Middle East hasn't been a peaceful
place since world war two but the wars
that have been fought there have with
one exception been very small yes that's
true and that exception is the iran-iraq
war most most of the wars in the Middle
East that we've seen have been short and
duration casualty rates been by mid 20th
century standards tiny Europe has been
historically a far more violent place
than the Middle East it's only very
recently that our propensity for
slaughtering one another within European
civilisation has finally been tamed I
mean they did a pretty good job right
but even before then think of the 30
Years War Protestants and Catholics have
inflicted more violence of one other
over the long delay than Sunnis and
Shias all for that matter Arabs and Jews
and one should bear that in mind before
passing judgments on the region we're
gonna have to wind down Christian you
have to catch a car to the plane but
would be interesting to get from one of
the questions here what prepares us
better for the future prepares us better
for the future a pessimistic promoter
and optimistic approach
oh well I'll take it you're mean there's
no catalyst it's an optimistic approach
and I and I say that for very simple
reason that I think it is you know I'm
struck by as it as Antonio Graham sees
quote about the pessimism of the
intellect and the optimism of the will
that is that we need to think hard about
how hard and difficult the challenges
are but we need to be able to imagine
that we can overcome them that if we
fail to achieve greatness if we fail to
meet the challenges that things like
climate change or ethnic conflict or the
challenges at a place like China with
its environmental and energy challenges
represents I think they are mostly
failures to be able to imagine better
possibilities that motivate people to do
things that are different from their
historical inclinations so we come to
the question of the probabilities to be
attached to scenarios and the weights to
be applied to them and it seems to me I
take a completely different view from
you the most important scenario the one
you should think about most is the worst
case scenario that is the one to focus
on because that is the one that will
blow you up
Goldilocks can take care of herself
and as for Pangloss he's just fine the
key thing is to look very hard for that
worst-case scenario and make sure you
have got it right now the argument for
historical study that I want to conclude
with is this you could try and rely on
your own imagination to come up with a
worst-case scenario you can do it just
from first principles fine but I believe
you will do better at identifying that
worst-case scenario you will come up
with a better range of possible
nightmare outcomes if you study history
[Laughter]
and remember ladies and gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen if you way to go
outstanding people thank you
[Music]
you